>> Bryan: SKATES IT GOOD INTERCY
CHIAROT SHOWING THE
KUBALIK, LONG SHOT AND JAKE CIR.
>> Jamie: RECOGNIZE NO STICK.
JOHNSON WITHOUT A POEHLING.
FLEURY STAYED WITH HIM.
TUESDAY.
>> Mike: THAT IS TEAM USED TOCHG
T
WE FELT HE WAS, KEEPING US CHILL
WITH A LAUGH IN MONTREAL TERRIT.
>> Mike: THAT IS JUST IT.
SEE HIMFFORT
TO EVANST.
MONTREAL IS NOT IN A TOUGHTHE B.
TOOK THE PUCK OFF THE WALL AND
BRINGS IT TO THE MIDDLE OF THE
ICE IF YOU C
HIM.
BRANDON HAGEL WAITIN GOODNESS!MS
MUCH OFFENSIVE-ZONE TIME ASEDS .
KANE
>> Mike: IN FRONT.
TOEWS IN THE HIGH SLOT.
RUN-- BUT RYAN
IT IS JAKE McCABE.
>> Mike: ROMS DRAWING S IS
NOT A TRADITIONAL BUTTERFLY
GOALIE OR STAND UP GUY.
COULDN'T GET IT IN DEEP.ND NOW
KUKU KUBALIK, AND HE IS
WAITING.
AGAIN.
>> Mike: CARPETTER IS ACTING
LIKE A EQUATION, AND THAT IS
DEBRINCAT, AND THEY'LL CLEAR THE
ZONE YOU SEE THOSE LOOSE PUCKS
YOU HAVE TO COMMIT RIGHT AWAY A.
>> Bryan: YEAH.
THREE STANLEY CUP
CARPENTER THE HACK JOB.
CAN'T TAKE IT.
HE CAN'T WRAP IT.
THAT LEAN..
>> Mike: AT SOME POINT HE IS
GOING TO NEED A NIGHTEHIND THE .
DROUIN CAN'T GET THE SHOT.
CAUFIELD TRIES TO TUCK IT IN
TAKE THEIR TWO POINTS
AN